قد للامير هاري اليوم بشهاده امام المحكمه
العليا في لندن كاول فرد رفيع من العائله
المالكه بيمثل امام محكمه من 130 عام هذه
ادلب شاهدته في الدعوه لرفعها هو ومئه
شخصيه مشهوره ضد شركه ام جي ان اللي بتصدر
صحف ديلي ميرير
باختراق هواتفهم المحموله والنشر معلومات
بطريقه غير قانونيه هاري كان لازم يحضر
امس جلسه المحاكمه ولكنه تغيب عنها لانه
طلع متاخر من امريكا لانه كان بيحضر عيد
ميلاد بنته بعيدها ثاني الاميره طيب دفاع
ام جي ان قالوا انه غيابه كان مو عادي
والقاضي كمان اندهش من عدم حضوره الجلسه
طيب مثل ما قلنا هذه من 100 شخصيه رافعه
القضيه لكنه واحد من اربعه بس راح يشهدوا
امام المحكمه وشاهدته مستمره للساعات
اليوم وبكره كمان مكمله استجواب وراح يتم
من قبل محاميين وهو ومن قبل محامين الد عن
المؤسسه الصحفيه الاكيد الان وللكل يبغى
يعرفه هو تفاصيل شهاده الامير واللي بتغطي
33 مقال هو مقدمهم بيقولوا ان المؤسسه
الصحفيه حصلت على المعلومات اللي فيهم عنه
بشكل مقانوني شهاده الامير كانت من خمسه
وخمسين صفحه وبعدها بدات الاسئله
والاستجواب وملخص اللي قالوا امام المحكمه
ممكن اقول لكم هو انه هو قال بدايه انه هو
رافع دعوه على الشركه لانها حصلت على
معلومات عنه بطريقه غير قانونيه وقال انه
هو طول حياته كان بيشعر انه في انتهاك
لحياته الخاصه من الصحافه الصفراء وانه في
كل علاقاته ان كان صداقه او علاقه عاطفيه
وفي الجيش وحتى في علاقته بالعائله كانت
دائما في طرف ثالث هو الصحافه الصفراء
وهذا الشيء يسبب لوءو للاطراف الاخرى
المعنيه بيرنويا متواصله يعني كده حاله من
الذعر والخوف الامير قال كمان انه قراره
بالتنحي عن واجباته الملكيه لعب في دور
كبير التطفل ومضايقات الصحافه اللي اثرت
بشكل كبير على حالته النفسيه والعقليه
هاجم الامير كمان هاري الاعلامي الشهير
بيرسمورجن اللي كان رئيس تحرير لصحيفه
ديلي ميرور اللي هي من بين الصحف المعنيه
بالدعوه واللي معروف عنه بيهاجم دائما
هاري وزوجته ومن الاشياء اللافته في شهاده
حديثه عن تاثير الصحافه السلبي في حياه
امه الراحله الاميره ديانا وكمان قال انه
هو ما رفع الدعوه علشان وبس لكن لانه
بيشعر انه كعضو حتى لو انه هو عضو غير
عامل في العائله المالكه وكعسكري ايضا في
الجيش فعليه مسؤوليه فتح اي نشاط اجرامي
بيتم تحت مسمى الاهتمام بالراي العام
وبعيدا عن مضمون الشهاده فمن الاشياء
اللافته اللي نقلها الصحفيين حاضرين
للجلسه انهم اول مره بيسمعوا محامي بيعطي
تعليمات للمتحدثين في الجلسه كيف يخاطبوا
الشاهد فالمحامي شرح لهم ان البروتوكول
بيقول انه اول مره توجهوا له كلام تخاطبوه
فيه لازم صاحب السمو الملكي بعدها لما
تخاطبوا تقدروا تقولوا الامير هاري طيب من
لندن معنا الكاتبه الصحفيه جوسيلين ايليا
اهلا فيك معنا جوسيلين طيب انا دائما
مشكلتي مع الاخبار المتعلقه بالامير هاري
انه هو بيتحدث دائما عن رغبته في الخصوصيه
واهتمام الصحافه في والكلام هذا كله والان
طبعا رافع قضيه والكلام هذا كله وفي نفس
الوقت هو صراحه اعطانا كميه تفاصيل عن
حياته الشخصيه في السنوات الاخيره اكثر
مما كنا نحتاج اصلا اننا نعرف
صح انا كتير حبيت السؤال ساره لانه بالفعل
هيك ما فينا ننكر انه الصحافه ببريطانيا
ممكن تكون صحافه متطفله يعني التاريخ
دائما عم بعيد نفسه يعني فينا نقول
الصحافه الصفراء عم نحكي عن التابلت انه
هيك بتعمل عاده
بتستحصل على المعلومات بطريقه ما فيها نوع
من الادب بطريقه
مش مقبوله لانه بطريقه ممكن وصفه بغير
شرعيه
حاليا انه اصلا المؤسسه الاعلاميه اعتذرت
سابقا عن انها فعلا تجسست هاتفيا او على
الهواتف يعني ايه
عندهم سوابق وقدت كمان احدى الحوادث
لاغلاق يعني صحيفه معروفه ومرموقه جدا فما
فينا نقول انه الصحافه بريطانيا ما بتقوم
بمثل هذه الاعمال المشيله ولكن لما بدنا
نحكي عن الامير هاري وعن انه قديش هو
بناشد بانه بطالب انه يكون في عنده حريه
شخصيه وما بحب الناس تتبعوا ولكن بادي
الدعايه اللي عملها لنفسه ولا زوجته بعد
اطلاق كتابه هذا يعني هذا الموضوع وحده
يعني كافه لحتى يكون ماده دسمه للصحافه
فهو اول شيء قالوا اليوم بامتثاله قدام
المحكمه اللي تغيب عنه مثل ما انت تفضلتي
وقلتي امس انه قال انه الصحافه هون صورت
لاله صوره معينه يعني لعبوا هم بالاشياء
اللي هو ممكن يقوم فيها بالحياه لما كان
عمره 20 سنه كان شاب طايش فصورته
[موسيقى]
قال له انه عن قضيه التنصت فراح يكون في
ثغرات مش منتبه للامير هاري انا برايي
خاصه انه هو بيقول انه تنصتوا على
مكالماته الخاصه على هاتفه الجوال سنه 96
ولكن هو بنفس الوقت بيقول بانه بهذا العام
لم يكن يملك هاتفا جوانا لا يعني صراحه
اصلا يعني بقول لك بعد كتابه زي ما ذكرتي
هو تحدث مثلا عن اعضاءه الخاصه يعني اكثر
من عشر مرات جت سيرتها في الكتاب تفاصيل
ما كنا محتاجين ابدا انه نحن نعرفها بس
اذا حابين نضيف لهذا الكلام والجدل الكلام
من الكلام اللي هو قاله هو كمان هاجم
الاعلام طبعا بشكل صريح وقال انه هو في
القاع وهذا هجوم دائما مستمر عنده ولكن
اليوم كمان في الشهاده قال الحكومه ايضا
في القاع الحكومه البريطانيه في القاع لما
تيجي من امير بريطاني بارز يعني هذا يعتبر
ابدا شيء غير مسبوق وكسر للقواعد يعني
ساره انت بتقري افكار انا كان بدي اتطرق
لهذه النقطه يلي هي كتير كتير مهمه هو
صحيح يعني داخل بهالمعركه القانونيه الى
جانب مئه شخصيه ولكن هل شخصيات يلي داخلين
بهالمعمعه هايدي هن شخصيات بارزه بعالم
الفن ولكن ممنون فهو بالترتيب الخامس
بالعائله المالكيه فهو شخصيه مرموقه وهو
فرد من افراد العائله المالكه لما بيحكي
اليوم وبيقول انه
الحكومه في عندها تواطئ مع الصحافه
ببريطانيا وهي تلعب دور يعني الشيطان
الاخرس هون في هون في خطوره لانه هو هو
اللي طلب من
المحكمه انه يتوجهوا له باسم الامير هاري
وليس دوقس هذا كان خياره الشخصي فانت
موجود كامير فما بحق لك التطرق حتى لو كان
هالشي هذا
صحيح وانا ما عم بنفع عن يعني طريقه
التعامل بين الصحافه الصفراء التابلود
بريطانيا وبين الحكومه ولكن بما انه هو لا
يزال يحمل اللقب الملكي لازم يكون عنده
انتباه اكثر لما بده يتطرق لمواضيع شائكه
جدا الصحافه البريطانيه يمكن واحده من
التعليقات اللي قالتها انه في مئه مشهور
داخلين في هذه القضيه لكن الامير هاري هو
الوحيد اللي محول الموضوع لانه حلقات من
برنامج اوبرا طبعا المقدمه الشريره واللي
كان عندها كثير دراما في الحلقات اللي
بتقدمها وطبعا هو عمل معاها مقابله هو
وميجان وعمل يعني عملوا قمه كانت البدايه
الانطلاقه للجرامه طيب جوزيلين انا بشكرك
جدا طبعا احنا راح نستمر في المتابعه نحنا
بنتكلم انه احنا غدا ايضا تستمر
المحاكمه كانت معنا من لندن الكاتبه
الصحفيه جوسيلين اللي شكرا لك